here in southern Nevada North Las Vegas
is trying to crack down on catalytic
converter thefts yesterday City Council
Members outlined a new proposal to ban
the possession or the sale of any
catalytic converter well unless you can
prove it's yours North Las Vegas Police
signed off on the action officers say
this could deter the ongoing theft
happening in our community
6 35 so we've seen a lot of Business
Development and growth up in North Las
Vegas of course we've seen companies
expand bringing lots of jobs and a lot
of investment into that part of the
valley so important are Laura negretti
joining us now with another drop in the
bucket for new business out there we
love
how it impacts people because of the
jobs Lauren
no definitely I'm so glad you said that
that's we want to talk about this block
here but yeah I am standing in a dirt
lot right now but it will soon be a
nearly 60 000 square foot building four
Club Industries and black Development
I've got them with you right here
Brandon Graves so Heather was just
saying right now you know this we talked
about economic boom and the coming to
the valley here jobs and everything
let's talk a little bit more about that
what can we expect
yeah so this project is two years in the
making we've been working with a tenant
that's going to occupy the building
Reese group and marasco supply and
they're going to be creating 50 to 75
jobs here at their new headquarters with
their state-of-the-art showroom and
there's going to be hundreds of more
jobs created ancillarly with their
ability to help with Home Improvements
definitely and you know this is actually
just like some of the of the building
there's actually still some space for a
new tenant to come in too
yeah we've got an additional 20 000
square feet that we're marketing and we
we look forward to another great tenant
that will provide even more jobs
definitely perfect many closing thoughts
here when we talk about you know this
new thing coming to the area
I'm just excited to be here excited to
have an impact on the community and give
back and be able to drive by an area
that is uh that is better than than the
way that we found it perfect
thanks so much should be a great event
that ground baking 8 30 this morning
live in Las Vegas not even North Las
Vegas learning ready eight news now